[Music]
that is some hot music Rob I love that
song
yep so hi welcome everybody to our live
stream I'm Eric that's Rob hi we get the
fun pleasure of playing rocket League on
switch it launched today Rob and thanks
to our friends at rocky Lee for
sponsoring this stream it's gonna be a
fun time it is it's gonna be a grand old
time
another reason to play rocket League
Eric like I know right and I'll so Rob
isn't even playing docked on a pro
controller I'm gonna be on his team with
my good ol handheld port and Peters
outside he's got the hots and his car
cuz he's a hacker cuz he got it we even
locked it we got that hot Mario Luigi
combo with Samus I guess so the cool
thing is multiplayer we can play with
people on PC mm-hmm Xbox we will try to
get through our competitive matches you
also play local co-op with Peter play it
which we will try later oh we are oh man
we are gonna try that later for sure
something else it's great I mean it
works I don't know like we uh I've not a
fan of the joique on controllers but I
was surprised like it actually does work
out you said if you wanted to have a fun
all the time at the bar bring your
switch
yeah if you want to go to a party and
ask excuse me where's your guest room
and bring a friend and then just isolate
yourself yeah totally gets the job done
all right fine start queuing a match oh
yeah sure why not
well I fixed this cuz you wanted us in
the top-left instead of the bottom left
I felt the top left makes the most sense
I defer to you sir we're loading up yeah
Peter got the sanest car you start off
if you purchase game you just
automatically get the Luigi i'ma do
brothers they uh which makes which movie
all day they see yeah which it might be
a movie you know what just bit of
Despicable Me that that works that works
for me I I like this pic well I think
minions are funny I think minions are
funny okay they can be alright
I don't like cry from laughing but I
we're not talking about also our rocket
League review will be up later this
furthest which is right here we go
though here we go I turn it up a little
bit
because I want to I want to show you the
coolest part about the mario / luigi
cars the mario sound effect is not good
Robert jump no it's not good no these
guys so we are playing I got it pro here
No
[ __ ] leagues better teamwork yep nope
that worked I Peter followed up boost oh
my got it okay nice work Rob good thing
we're on your feed okay close I was not
even thought oh I'm a semi-pro yesterday
I was a rook oh really I'm still broke
for sure so yeah we are playing on the
Nintendo switch Rocky League is out in
the wild on the switch and you're
thinking about picking it up oh shoot I
should be defending its pretty solid
handheld I'm playing handholds right now
Rob's playing on the pro controller
obviously so we can get some hot feed of
that yep oh yeah you do yeah I mean
anything's obviously gonna be better
with the controller all right that was
so bad yeah I think that it's only by oh
no no I was right I was right to play
yeah controller but this is totally
totally pretty good yeah sweet wait
where's what a pass [ __ ] I forgot all my
other nope there it is whoop it's fun
it's it's fun to like Peter and I were
playing last night he was like in and
out of matches like I play one and then
play with alan and then play one he's
like yeah I was like making food oh [ __ ]
that was all my fault
that was all my fault so I looked up a
chat for a second that's fine we can
afford it I was looking at how much is
it uh it's I believe it's 20
I mean rocket League has always been
yeah yeah oh that guy's got the Sam's
car - I'm Jellico desi yeah hi dear
Oh do it come on oh I'm sorry I took it
for Peter oh [ __ ] I'm sorry it's okay he
couldn't hear you from out there
normally we would be calling it we'd be
spouting the pit we'd be screaming in
the office which is actually probably a
good thing that we're not doing that Oh
Oh run at run it I got snow boots back
now that guy watched it damage good I'm
going to try to get it
here we go this is getting real messy
you were running into cars at this point
oh that's good oh you know run it
that's good hit oh I'm so sorry nope
I got it oh yeah combined right over his
head Bob how's the mine Oh kind of ass
nope I'm not really set it so ever
Oh Peter why Oh
oh yeah yeah maybe do it come a little
fake yeah so cross-platform does work
rate that Fox one in PC yeah Graham
pretty solid we do miss you Josh aw I
saw you talking that Koresh earlier but
I'll forgive you we miss our one of our
rocket League brothers raksha rocket
League Brodin part of the fam yeah we do
like us rocket League yeah we do feel
like it fell off a little bit once we
kind of a lot we used to be able to do
like five 3d trees in the office and
yeah I mean that was harder that's
that's where I drift off is when you're
playing but there's a couple times where
we stayed late like you mean theater we
played at a good little sash or won't we
get the alumni back in here like Chris
waters will come in yeah you'll come in
fiend in one sever it like once a
quarter oh sorry
does the person having game achievements
like the other versions that's a good
question I don't know about that I like
which ones like which achievements I
mean I guess some thing I'm thinking of
achievements there must be some for like
like ps4 are there stuff didn't transfer
over though no nothing transferred over
which is which is a little unfortunate
you know as someone who like put some
time until like ps4 with crates and such
oh what a save yo clear it
I got a crate last night I don't know if
I'm what am I gonna do with it
Peter got you samus you see the key you
need the key
oh but you get to think with it five
crates of the same times you can turn it
in Peter Oh Peter I don't know about
that
I don't know about that one either
almost okay well clear it out what clear
it out we just got a hang tight for a
minute hang tight play a strong
defensive game keep fenceless champions
Rob oh oh oh for my angle it looks
pretty good so that's the is it just the
two cars for now Sam it's in the Mario
Luigi I believe those the only only yes
so the way the Mario Luigi cars work is
it's actually just one car but depending
on the team you're on it'll switch
either to Mario or Luigi yeah it's kind
of one the same also the Samus car looks
way better definitely looks cool yeah it
looks better orange though like Peters
blue I can't tell that it's like right
it's got like a purple oh no again
knocked around yeah guys there's one guy
that's doing a lot of joking
Oh cuz he's probably pissed he owed Fred
piss he's losing to the Mario Brothers
oh crap nice that was all part of my
plan
oh we're chilling yeah how many more
matches do we have though like so we can
hit competitor Carly seven
oh that's a beauty Oh way to finish it I
believe it has all the DLC I didn't
check far enough Cala T for the Back to
the Future car but it had the Fast and
Furious cars I'm pretty sure it's in
here we just have to go look back Oh too
soon yeah there is a showroom like it
looks very identical yeah the other ones
Spenser babes is saying that all DLC is
purchasable so oh you got wheat I got a
common topper as well yeah I feel like
Peter got the Sam's car early on a pony
oh man you can play this wherever you go
the only thing would be internet
connection so you can't play online
obviously if you don't have internet
connection but you could play like
training or local probably against like
boss and stuff like that yeah pretty
good stuff thank you guys all for tuning
in hanging out with me and Rob on this
fine rocket league launch day mmm it's
like a good excuse to come back we fell
off a little bit we did have those like
sessions every now and then when you
know Chris would come in or like or like
nobody would fire it up or like rumble
pit oh yeah they had some fun mode the
bat the hoops was pretty good I think
rumble pit was who was the one Christ I
can remember you someone in the chat
might have to remind me the one that was
last time we're like the floor would Oh
could remove the floor and that was like
the most I would say basketball a splice
or is like dunking and everything yeah
it does boot you out here so yeah if it
doesn't find a match it just sends you
back to the main screen right in time
standard that's tuned so we have a new
banner yet I'm not feeling so it's just
like rocket League you're slowly
unlocking these and I got the Merc the
gizmo the octane you got all those
standard cars
oh you show the showroom Oh show room
actually that actually might boot me but
oh you think maybe it's like a whole
nother menu that's pretty cool Aquadome
well silence solid was not a fan of
hockey I thought hockey was fine
yeah hockey that was the first one it
was different like that pup just became
frustrating sometimes did they say drop
shot was name of it thank you that's
toliet do I love drop shot hanging back
sort of whoa whoa that nope not
intentional top it's also cool that a
show us the story all right yeah we'll
do that in a bit check that out
how's the connection on the switch it's
seven solid four Rob who's a directly
connected and okay I just saw that
message I will deal with that
we had some a little bit of stream head
up somewhere but
Oh get a second goal here while I yeah
so that I can just not worry about no
Peter Peter all right Pete ah you're
good take a little break I would say
move around your controller a little bit
just so you don't get kicked
here we go better off
there they go and back
I like the engine noise for this car Oh
what's going there
oh no problem oh sorry if we're getting
really loud
but hey no you're so rocky you were
talks you were talking about me no oh
again just as loud cool
yeah alright three three nil as I would
say
Oh Oh
oh you're either all the word amis
studying it up
get this I'll just follow that no
problem put you in my backpack and I'll
carry the teens what uh no Peter Sam I
know don't bring your home
I'll go for any another oh come on oh
it's all right here good I try to see if
I could get it fly that guy but he's not
having it
now up too much it's a good good lord I
know why we're looking at my feet I
don't know we're good
it's all the same oh nice little whiff
yeah I just wanted to show you guys how
hi Mario Luigi could get yeah sure it's
all about teamwork baby
yes we were all good on Facebook he
recyclers released n that to them Oh
said it Peter said it Oh Jack man 1981
oh yeah
I'll sit here oh that guy just Dookie
oh did not
run it oh that guy's not having keep
keep keep it going
well that's waiting for ya as I go set
it uh no problem hot how about this oh
what a play by that guy
how's your little shift how's your
little tip play there chip microchip aru
keeping a little lie yeah he's got a
follows oh yeah
Wow that was a little touch pass that
landed right in front of you
yes calculated is correct Danny oh they
forfeited hmm I would feels good feels
good I wish for them
holy moly oh look at you you got a bobby
helmet
I got a hot wheel that's exactly what I
wanted man I just want I just want that
Sammis car man can't we just roll three
Sammis bars and I want the same as I
know how we got it so early
oh look at the store is that one store
let's see you how that goes so we get
the hot music in the Oh Josh st. Peter
so hot right now
it's so hot totally
look at that okay wow that is bad that's
faster than some of the movement yeah
look at the ice charger yeah we let's
shine twin mill I want a song I I like
yeah pick a song you like I go I go
through a lot of these let's just work
in tabletop mode he is so hot oh wow
that skull wow wow yeah you see
everything pretty well on the handheld I
would say the only thing I've noticed is
when you're really far away from the
ball everything was a lot smaller and
the depth of field is a little bit
harder to see but it's probably just me
trying to get used to it I think it
plays totally fine handheld pretty good
and even Robin Peter said that they
played on joy Khan's split screen which
we will do at some point later and yeah
they said it was pretty good actually
surprisingly yeah I mean it's it's not
the ideal way to play but it was totally
like it was worth messing around with
like if you want to show some rocket
League like hey oh yeah this Allen pop
this joy Khan off we're like you know I
recently took a flight to the East Coast
with my brother and like we both were
playing on the switch like that's that
was totally a doable fact like way to
play alright let's do this yeah I just
you know the cars are all here I guess I
mean that's really the only thing as far
as the store right I mean other than
like opening crates and stuff like that
yeah but there you go
let's play let's do it should we play a
different mode drop shots is up to you
let's play drop shot alright
nope that's not I want to do okay yeah
it's in the bottom right you're right
yeah there's only 368 people playing but
hopefully we find a game not or maybe
you not a phase q for both and then like
we get surprised hey we found a game
server sick yeah it looks pretty good I
don't know if you guys would see this a
little blurry probably focus focus
I'd have to focus but uh pretty solid
like if you have a good Wi-Fi to your
you're fine like I was playing in my
place I totally forgot how to play this
this mode or whatever just don't let it
hit the ground like that on your side oh
that's bad news yeah give it to him Rob
cute
no you stay on this side
oh nice Oh kind of that it may have hit
the ground there so the people for
people that don't know the premise of
this is like I think it takes over there
you go so you want to charge up the ball
like that and I think it takes like it
tastes like three or three hits to
remove a tile on the opposing teams and
your team as well for if you want to
keep the ball off your floor like hot
potato and back onto there so you can
make a goal and then dunk it
oh I got blew me up oh that's right but
it has to be your color so I have to hit
it last and then it has to hit therefore
that's right so you want to hit it again
thinking of infinite boots - yeah yeah
or recharges yeah darn oh that's looking
good
I'm looking good there's takes a little
minute all air it is so it's actually
it's not it's not three times it's twice
yeah because it's already thinking I
just blow these guys
you could that could be a tactic oh yeah
I think this guy's
oh never could forget
it's our color that hit it yeah so we're
good just gotta hit it again
get a rub oh oh nice oh yeah
oh no good okay
got it again oh it's it's happening Oh
[Music]
Mary kiss coach Kisch in the house oh
are you winning yeah it's a you'll
notice as the floor starts to fall apart
that uh you know it's cool how they were
able to by evolve just do normal game
types and then the only unfortunate
thing about scoring a goal is that their
size the opposing side gets white yeah
reset so we have to really give it all
we got
oh yeah oh I touched it and jerk nope
get down stars but now what did some
some damage there
oh nice
oh yeah
touch that oh that's a fat Oh Oh what's
freestyle they want to see some
freestyle yeah I don't know what
freestyle is not crazy is that a game
mode no this is pretty fun though like
as it as mentioned I'm playing handheld
Rozz playing docks Peters outside right
now you got all your like chat wheel is
still on the D pads
I'd kind of forgotten some of them had
to kind of like really all that came
back pretty much I got it team but
depends if you customize it well it's
also because I've been playing handheld
and I don't know it just feels a little
bit different I'm sorry Peter I'm house
fall hog oh yeah yeah oh oh oh there's a
there's a hole there wind produce here -
oh excuse the pot yeah probably
unless he's a human in disguise like
saber-tooth might be a bot - how are you
playing BOTS no no oh oh no we are it
take that yeah box these BOTS
goddammit oh yeah Paul Connor Connor is
by himself okay so he's actually got
pain sorry Connor oh you got the Samus
icon though yeah lucky ducky yeah we're
having quite a lot of fun I mean we like
rocket League already and like I don't
know pretty good I mean I first touch I
purchased rocket League for including
like PC I think a couple times in order
to make yeah in order to make things
happen we're like hey we want to play
some dude do we buy the bundle oh that's
right it was the bundle I bought yeah
you're right oh another one like Peters
post-school how does this version
compared to the other platforms asked
battle pants I think it's a pretty
pretty similar the only things like I
said on handheld for me like if you're
let's say you're playing the goal
defending the ball looks kind of smaller
than it would on a normal screen so it's
a little bit harder to tell if you
should kind of come out and play I don't
want to say like graphically it's
probably better on a little bit slightly
better on the other consoles but I mean
really this game's not about the
graphics right it's about being able to
play and the most important part is that
like us playing like it feels fought
like good to me like it doesn't none of
that really affects my you know my yeah
like yeah like with a controller most
important part with the controller it's
fine I would say like handheld was a
little different but I could it was one
of the things worried like in my head I
was like okay I got the hang of it it's
a little different but yeah again I've
said it before but like something like
doom first-person as a first-person
shooter it's it's it's tough it's tough
to use joy cons first
then but again like with a game like
this dude I think it works pretty well
yeah silence all I asking is the
framerate stable and more chaotic modes
I mean that's we've only really tried a
couple of those so I mean what's really
that chaotic maybe Rumble well the maps
right I would say that's the only time
where I think frame rates can maybe drop
a few like but regardless I haven't
found anything to be like oh I'm sorry I
was still in the match
oh no
invite me doing new one no I didn't I
don't know you know that's my bed I was
looking at chatter can you read by me in
a second once I'm out oh what's up Asian
gamer bro thanks for stopping by
go for it oh god I said no duty why
would it default as no there you go okay
so I was spamming you okay
all right back god that same as car
looks pretty cool I thought it looks a
lot better than orange oh for sure yeah
i mean when i get the mario bros i do
like the the jump noise sound effect boy
and then you got the star which would
call it rocket boost default yeah pretty
good stuff
I want I want my Dominus though Dominus
or mess of muscle movements money less
man I don't know
[Music]
we're playing my version I got was oh
that's a great question actually don't
know I'm not sure on that one sorry I
mean the original game I whipped it oh I
thought that guy was gonna go for it and
he didn't over over complicating things
oh the rumble is good too it feels get
the rumble yeah that was Daniel
are you gonna go for the distance talk
about a hole-in-one
you can play oh you're right I should've
saved it for you
it's okay oh there it is come back
Oh
oh yeah putting us in his backpack way
they split screen with two separate joy
cons asked portal Scout yes we can we
will totally do that
game next game give it a girl give it go
I know it's gonna be a tough all right
we can't I kept thinking like we'd have
to undock it for some reason oh no yeah
we totally can could totally I'm gonna
shine a second
it does split screen yeah you'll see
well it'll be my first time seeing it to
you but she'd be good I think the only
thing is to play online oh I think we
might need to have two Nintendo accounts
Oh on the same thing yeah wheat Peter
and I just did like against bots but I
think just because of how Nintendo's
accounts us and work like I don't know
if they have a context for sin where
it's like Rob one rub two yeah I'm not
positive about what we could find out
okay oh yes oh my god that was a no slag
yeah that was no niat it was it was not
had nothing beats my skill
[ __ ] okay we're good
they said it Oh should wait it a hot
it's too much
never been great at Ariel I could really
- we should not and he's always out
run it Rob I'm trying okay oh this guy
oh why am I the way I am here we go
duties last minute like slide rolls
thinking I needed like adjust but then I
just over it yeah I did that I was doing
that to where darn it alright you know
what let's get rid of this amazeballs
No you got it I could have had I
couldn't it was my fault
look how deep I having the goal I was
like oh I'll block this shot and I was
like oh no he's hitting it let me
reverse and then nope all right here we
go
what's up random carrot random carrot oh
they love it I love carrots no don't
bounce in good safe it's all I'm good
for
sometimes oh I'm sorry
that's star shit's weird because I'm
hearing your audio alright oh crap I was
trying to kill the guy
it's okay it all worked out they didn't
see it coming it's like the meta one
step ahead of them know something
uh-oh
dang it
to saves Oh
Oh
it's okay we wanted to show everyone
it's time for a time this is a
cross-platform enable the Lukas so we're
playing against like PC people possibly
Xbox one people it is not only against
which people
Oh for that new
go pina
oh I just said it
oh we still got it we still got it no we
don't okay maybe we do your still time
Rob believe smells like some ot oh it's
not keep it alive Rob
you know I got it all at least to get it
out oh god it's coming back in there
nice that do anything wrong oh god
there's that extra wall Carrie I played
that bad Tommy oh you got it I got the
breakout I'm glad we took that loss then
yeah well we have to go switch this oh
you gotta switch that out
I think it's cross platform it's only PC
and Xbox one with switch I don't think
it's with PlayStation 4 yeah we get that
Samus body I'm surprised it's just a
common I mean you gotta get this
eventually you know if you made it a
rare trademark damn now I'm the only
Mario brother left
[Music]
huh alert I looked good good Eric alert
alert looks like we only got one Mario
brother left
Dan's I need Santa's card come on game
I will I believe they should be able to
see the UH Nintendo skins Paul the
Nintendo skins on other platforms hey I
like what would it look like if it
wasn't right so I'm sure it's in the
game Oh split-screen yeah
hey this body switch exclusive I'm not
actually sure about that is he famous
yeah oh it's totally exclusive ok so
like they aren't earn it then they just
see us in the fans bar or it's no
different than when Rockley came to xbox
with the Warhawk alright alright so
goddamn okay I think we have to rebind
controllers oh are we doing the are we
doing the thing I don't see what they're
doing it back out of the party you need
to quit leave the party to quit alright
alright
oh maybe I won't get to play as a
Santa's car then
L&R
well let's see this is I'm so bad at
this
so this is embarrassing so then I do
like to turn off my pro controller so
should be able to but have to go out to
the other menu don't mind us no it is
but it still got my pro controller
registers I think I had to like go to
the main menu and read and read I don't
think that's the case cuz like we're not
as playing with John Luke he just kind
of popped one on and one off for the
like let's do this just hear me out okay
you doing your way this is the second
one change grip order okay so now do it
so now do those two okay now did the
other one there's that okay okay and do
that one too as well cuz I did I did do
mine you gotta do yours oh yeah there
you go okay yeah you keep going there
you go go up uh-huh okay okay just pick
anyone do Chewie yeah Chewie oh I could
grab the Chewie mask right now I told
you choo so this is the only situation
is I have to sign in and link this thing
is I don't have a second account created
really okay but you can try signing
links see what that does Wow where are
the buttons it's gonna be a little it's
not you'll fuel figured out pretty quick
I mean it's like yeah this thing so just
we can't create a counter now so it's do
you know yours by heart I think so
if you know yours my heart I'm gonna be
impressed this is not the way to view
yeah I'll get with small I'll give it a
little tutorial so this is what we're
using blocking it so it's no different
than like you know like another
controller so you got your gas
this is boost this is jump
this is handbrake I really wish I was
paying I'm gonna this is camera ball a
lot ball lock oh did I screw that up
yeah you did I totally did this is how
you you drive the car with this I have
it too worried if you if you you
customize your key bindings if you hold
down the stick you can do like the
manual roll in midair and then you got
your reverse brake and then so what do
you do when you like and that these
don't do anything when you want to like
freak am cuz the only free cam concern
ences let me in did this work yeah I
think so yeah worked you dog I have to
use my phone for everything like that
all my passwords oh god was this okay
yep let me out of here continue all
right okay oh yeah now it back
oh no ex oh yeah you're still playing
okay Peters Dillon are you're in control
so you go do I get a change my car oh
you want to be Sam is that you
this is you know a my plant oh yeah okay
you're on the if I don't get to be samus
I'm gonna be livid yeah I don't I'll be
dog trying to take my patio or wall it
could be Louie dude it doesn't matter
yeah okay cool alright so what well man
this is different because I was using
the other one but we'll figure it out I
don't know I'll figure it out good luck
to us
should we do do it we can competitive
don't be afraid Rob I got a not press
that other random key I guess you're the
potty leader so you do push uh are you
oh you're the one that has samus it's
you Oh Peters the party leader I think
he is dang it dang it but I will quit
invite them so create party hit the hit
a or the top one for you god it's it's
different yeah yeah because we're having
to follow that follow the button but you
can you can do this you can do it all
right ease in alright competitive let's
do it so what is what the only way to
play gas reverse boost they don't do
anything so they're kind of hard to
avoid so I'd recommend just gripping
them and pushing them down all the way
just for no reason
[Music]
this should be interesting
oh we're gonna take them and we're gonna
write in the thing after that would be
don't want to shoot icons what's the
time in the US West I think it's like
roughly eleven forty four what's up
yonis and winkles from germany oh my god
it's so small all right here we go
oh it's not that bad I know I am hitting
those uh those weird bumpers a lot
though yeah I know I know you have to
mess around on the those little buttons
those of you I didn't I was watching
yeah I'm still a rookie oh we can't do
any a d-pad command things though no
you're right yeah that is the sending
that is a bus you're absolutely right I
don't even know if I should be attacking
this yeah the only thing that feels a
little awkward is pressing down on those
other buttons oh so this is kind of how
it looks like in handheld when the ball
is far away is what I kind of meant well
like there's definitely a dynamic
resolution go on so like I feel like
sometimes it'll like look better like
it'll it'll probably like sharpen up and
say oh dude I'm gonna go for it nailed
it nailed it so close
yep mm-hmm keeping alive oh that's hot
that's real hot let me just get out of
the way
that's all you almost backed off from it
King he's split screen and tablet mode I
want to say yes except the screens at a
lot smaller did you play in tablet yeah
we did it you want to be pretty close to
that thing you're you're practically
eating the screen at that point oh oh
yeah yeah well makes one more touch
well like the engine noises play
oh wow
Oh like oh my god
why do I keep doing a key role shoot
yeah
mm-hmm yeah that's right I was waiting
for that little tip but they got a look
oh no no no ha ha the only thing that's
been a little weird for me is like
trying not to press B yeah really hard
to not pressing like side besides
lovebirds but it's fine
get used to it if only game won and
we're winning so you know oh so I got
blown open oh no you know he did oh
there we go oh yeah come on oh oh oh
O'Reilly I don't wait we're not so sweet
we're sponsored by rocket League right
now man yeah you're right
uh-oh nope but maybe I said maybe shoot
yeah I'm having a problem
do it clear it
yeah
oh is it going we'll say my hands oh
there it is there it is cramping up a
little bit kind of got it thank God not
cramping but like my index finger on the
gas I'm just not used to playing on a
smaller controller
thattaboy I I would write something
Peter but I don't have the ability to
yeah suggested would be pro controller
handheld and then this would be your
third option your family fun Christmas
one show want to show the folks on
rocket League yes scheisse
now we're chillin oh go go go there's no
one back there no oh yeah yeah almost
big plays nope
Oh God I wanted to reverse with the
button so small
okay come on run it run it run it I got
no booze oh that's all you right there
slamma-jamma slow Rolla slow roll oh
yeah yikes
Nintendo boy says should I get a switch
I'm surprised your name is into the boy
advice weighted viewer games potentially
he says Isaac I don't know how we would
do a private match to invite anyone do
you know how we would do that do you
think that's possible
come on um I think we would have to be
Nintendo switch friends right oh it's
it's a fat one uh no one's there
but I'm here oh that's all you perfect
nailed it
oh that's good there it is
saved by the keeper boy the caper oh
yeah
darn it does my fault I should it does a
good pass old Eric would have made that
shot
they show not pass okay
jakers say tankers 1992 says just got le
1r on switch might get this also today
yeah there's a lot of games coming keep
wanting to say GG yeah got nothing to
press on the icon yeah we did it though
and I got some wheels we'll do one more
like this and then back to back to
normal just to make just to make sure
this guy see mattador stormed off there
cuz they knew he was happy that that you
got taken and buy some joy that's right
yeah I think we would have to be
switched friends potentially to do the
I'm pretty sure you do I don't know how
else you can like yeah invite someone
was like yeah I don't even know unless
you can do like create a game with name
and password like we used to on PC oh
right with the prizes yeah yeah we can
try that after yeah okay for those are
that you that are on other platforms we
can try that in a little bit
Xbox our PC that is there is no yeah
then Wilkinson saying watching this
makes him really want to switch there's
a there's no ps4 cross-platform right
damn it how is it like the play of joy
Khan's ass portal scout yeah I think
it's fine
this is like I said this would be my
third option I'd rather play with a pro
controller oh god I just came out of pro
controller or handheld would be my
preferred two ways
this totally works like I said he could
even play on the tablet which Rob and
Peter did the Rob said you just kind of
gotta get you played on a tablet god I'm
glad I mean what joy cons but you were
playing it just earlier down the stream
no no but I mean like split-screen oh
right like you and Peter played yeah oh
no I got it
how did I not get it safe for that yes
I'm all over the place put it off yep
uh-huh
Oh
yep go for you guys
[ __ ] rats no I got nope bad move
what no no why did I do that oh my god
that was a risky move I got
- whoa no need some damn either no Peter
whoa I'm gonna lying there little lady
but we didn't get the little Network
pop-up so just a little it was so it was
so quick Oh Oh No
oh come on
oops
no I'm not I should have just gone back
oh you have this ceiling okay okay
oh oh that's sure
not there anymore maybe I am Oh Oh a
little back tap by that guy who got that
now we got a competitive 0/0 match right
now
I hope this doesn't go into overtime
Oh No
Shh No okay that guy botched it yeah
okay go bina o horrible pressure oh my
god no they didn't have the angle
Oleg oh no oh no it's totally going
everywhere oh no tonight oh come on oh
just go Peter honey stop it oh god I
just with it Oh God
oh my gosh
what a slugfest
Wow
Oh God
your piece
Oh
what him dude he does by himself shipped
it to himself yeah but all of it but I
wasn't there actually back out let's go
let's go back to my way so yeah joy
coins totally good totally fine I would
say a third option third option third
option this would be oh you mean so
second option would be this guy and then
first option I would say play the the
pro controller if you have 100 pointless
video says great stream guys I can't
wait to get this now I was just going to
ask your opinions on this game I think
it's great I think it's awesome that you
can play portable if you have good Wi-Fi
I found playing on handle pretty pretty
solid also as we just showed you can
play a joke on split screen you can't
even play you know just if you're
standing up your switch it's a lot
smaller obviously but you could do that
if you wanted to we just played split
screen
I would like to reconnect to the servers
and get
oh you gotta kick me probably huh so I
think I did right or no this is right
here where you can try inviting me you
can see what that does to that other
wing version okay so that's going to be
the situation
yeah death gamer saying we would have to
create a room with the password so that
people can join we can do that we can do
that in 15 minutes we'll play a couple
my actually you know what we could do it
now if we wanted to
once he sorts out this party thing so
yeah thank you guys all for tuning in to
our rocky league launch day livestream
on the Nintendo switch thanks to our
friends at rocket league for sponsoring
this screen we appreciate it we I am
unsure how to kick you out of here why
don't you there you go
there we go as he says it do you want to
make a game then and see if people want
to join that if we get Peter and give it
a create a party I think first right
alright so for the guys in chat if you
guys want to try this we're gonna try
making a room and we'll play with you
all is the dock mode 1080s
Eduardo Vega I believe this switch
docked always outputs 1080 60 I believe
am i lying and went a liar it's just the
standard output of the dock yeah
in each game like changes like I don't
think I don't there we playing president
what better a while doesn't run it 60
are we're doing hi
yeah we're doing hot for before the name
in house or do name and password for
sure let's do this
champions feel name and password now
someone saying what nothing okay so
those you want to join this let's just
do GameSpot lowercase alright so here we
go guys
for the Xbox one slash PC users we're
gonna name the private match game spot
all lowercase and the password is GS GS
there you go
lowercase and we're gonna create that
match and the first I guess five people
let's show up there you go boom good
luck to the people coming in if we need
to swap people out we can always make
another match I guess Oh Tandy P is the
maximum output yeah I mean that I just
know that's what like we just are
capture we're doing the same thing I
just know that that's what all our cash
work women like reads the switch outfit
eyes it's kind of like the ps4 pro like
outputs like 4k 60 even though not all
the games or 40s right does anyone going
to join
all right bring it heater dropped no
just you know you just joined you're
just joining Oh are you gonna do the
over-the-top here
I guess he's waiting for you or are you
just trying to oh yeah let's go let's do
it oh what a sea
not today Robert oh we got mer dog 39
joining in the Matt Murdock sub Murdock
oh god I just
dammit I'm Kurt hug point and her dog
her you're gonna start with the deficit
guys currently Murtagh is on our team
Oh what okay bring it three on one no
problem
well I totally whip that you got it
though
oh yeah run it run it run it
back there for all of those at the NLX
Peter oh it's a game spot and the
password is GS all everything's
lowercase crap oh go go go go
nice little chip yep yep
I had no boots Shran mr. ette new word
of the day sure rats charades
oh they both went up and got it jerks
oh I just hit it in no yup getting the
same error code someone gonna hear cuz
oh we have cross-play turned off really
I thought no we'll check after this oh
it's not good Rob rains Jacob joined it
is out jack way of life
Jacob Decker oh no Jacob Jacob jakku
jakku all right we're down through yo
it's not a big deal Joshua just join the
match boom we got people joining or
you're saying the person that joined but
we're the hosts why was them having it
turn off the matter Oh Oh Rob
oh that's just that was awful
you Peter that's you that's you I'm off
it
Oh one more tap Peters a wily one with
that salmon scarred
Oh God what are you waiting over there
Murdock rubber goalie uh-oh oh I think
you should just let it go
didn't matter no I didn't what's going
out no yeah I think so
you lie I think it's going out I think
this is wide that things going why I
barely arrived no drug a toe a sorry
that you can't join not sure 100% that
first layer who joined has it disabled
everyone that game is on a switch
oh really okay so maybe yeah well hull
to look at the settings but maybe I
don't know but that's not on us though
it's it's the first person that's
joining these matches that is causing Oh
nightly nap that's what chat saying the
first person Oh cuz they have it off
where you have where D but we're the
hosts though so I don't know it's okay
all right we got Mike Jordan to match
now somehow I feel like well we turned
off BOTS so these can't be fake people
oh oh oh sorry Jacob those a little
quick damage that's such a good set
I popped it up which is not
good news but it worked out Oh Murdock
oh we can't get you can't get bagels
here 60 seconds we have a lot of work to
do oh my setting says Murdock
okay so we'll fix that for next game
sorry guys
[Music]
thirty seconds left on the clock I think
we can pull this off I think we can war
goals
ah all right we'll fix it for next one
somehow
keep it alive Rob oh don't worry I'll
fetch it
all right let's win this all right where
we'll fix it this game I guess you met
the back out come at the background
start a whole new one everyone that's
joining that is on a switch please turn
off your no cross play stuff we are
gonna back out and remake so whoever is
joining if you're on a switch please
turn off that uh turn off the turn off a
kiss turn off Oh Jacob Clini thanks for
joining will get another match going
here alright we'll make another match
here we will be fine oh we're gonna
we're gonna win this next one let's
change up the field here sorry we backed
out we're gonna make a new one what do
you want it do you want just call GS and
then make it shorter yeah let's make it
shorter okay the new uh rousseau FX I
don't know if you can party across
platform I just know you can join each
other's games G column Jacob if it's
your first time I hope you enjoy it and
the password is yes GS alright GS GS
here we go
Dave talks games yes nose out today Wow
too short too too short okay
sorry scratch that the GS GS
yeah yes GS is the name password is GS
there you go
there's that one song yeah alright here
we go music during barring yeah we
should be good
oh let's do we don't have the cross play
thing turn off right I want to be read
we have we should have it off I don't
know where we got Jacob in here we got
m1 kale we got toxic zombie no drug yeah
this has got to be working right cuz
everyone's joining yeah how was the
gameplay is it a bit pixelated I mean
like it's a little bit but not not
terrible it doesn't detract from the
actual gameplay
I mean like it's saying plays really
well oh it's a set toxic zombie Oh
pointless video says I'm in the game so
does Jacob awesome thank you guys for
joining in if I had Wi-Fi on my switch
I'd join in maybe next time kill the AE
alias death game were saying pointless
show us your skills
okay oh come on tell you look I already
know these guys are better than me yeah
oh well push there I don't know man
we're up 1 0 2 truth truth
I meant collectively Oh collective nah
dude believe oh where people is holy
enough for people at the chaos well know
how good they are birddog the aerial
game oh look at that that that's also hi
Oh save your husband processor and one
cable
oh and one care omer dogs got some Ariel
game I can see it what I should have
challenged oh no I feel like I'm
spectating alright it's coming hot oh
you got a little tap oh no that's ok
Anderson's back there it's okay either
way you got the samus card that's all
that matters right sure Oh
oh my gosh I watched it that was a hot
box
oh my god I'm horrible range
you must believe
oh yeah right over there noggin
Murdoch was there murder dog always
there older reliable no good get all not
to eat board oh nice oh yeah so for
those of you that don't know rocket
League is out on the switch today $20 on
the eShop I don't know I don't think
there's a physical copy yeah I don't
think so we got I mean there wasn't even
one for a console right
they had a collector's way down the line
I think a year later they have like a
collector's edition that it was physical
oddity
oh that's that's looking good that looks
good yeah great job and one Cale
yeah the file child the file size not
sure didn't seem that big though yeah
Wow the Grim Reaper that was close dad I
never seen that before
that wasn't the Reaper goal yeah is that
like a new Halloween thing that we
didn't get I mean wow I didn't know
those even existed that was like actual
animation to touch it Rob okay it all
work out that was really cool and
terrifying Oh everyone's going up high
there's like the ghosts of X rocket
League players all the salt all the salt
mounted into one animate one man
nice
nice
oh I was like watching it man God ah
Murdoch skip it skip it skip it skip
skip skip skip so bad
rear Halloween item says Kyle's winter
one yeah I'm back
oh he's going for the big plays I just
got to commit to going to the aerial for
that
oh nice work nice not today that's my
game oh that's a set
yeah I'll tap it too probably didn't
need to tap it again you got a chip it
on them
Thanks om k wa m1 k l was said he was in
position he was looking for a set oh I'm
so good
that's slow I didn't get the point of it
oh no all right we got close game here
will we survive Oh another little love a
little spinner Oh Oh My lordy the chaos
let's just watch for cars Oh
one two three four I haven't had any
framerate slowdowns the only thing we've
had is some connectivity here and there
by I'm on Wi-Fi so it happens pretty
typical like rocketry stuff
Oh
in there boom that was a hot goal right
there get over get over the top and use
my calculator easy I want a cool banner
like that
oops mode he says I don't know what that
snow it is so different oh oh is you
guys gonna run that in yep all the Grim
Reaper the Grim Reaper cometh he cometh
in he taketh that is pretty cool hello
I'm here to take anything
Oh guys see that part someone in chat
said that's
Oh cetera
good game GG did you hey everybody
rematch the framerate in split-screen
was I thought it was fine I'm not as
fine I have anything it was more the
resolution resolution yeah for sure
there's a couple of people spectating if
you guys have played let's try to be
kind and get some of the toxic zombie
here and mike and a couple people
waiting to yeah join now it looks like
some people bounced out so okay we're
here Kirk bury your oh yeah we're all
doing right uh yeah I guess I'm against
you now oh you're you're you were my
brother Anakin I had the high ground I
hate you no it wasn't it was great was
it I liked it
I mean compared to prepared a lot the
other and one your love brother you were
the chosen one
oh no one's back there we're dog that's
right I'm blue
oh you got Murtagh I got Murtagh and I
MK oh no murder dog with a little
reverse good stuff we already played
split screen memory man 3 if you go
check the DVR just scrub back you'll see
how that one uh that win we played two
matches I think both of them right yeah
for leaving so that uh no we lost the
other one went to overtime in every loss
oh that's right that one guy Santa Cruz
sank him
well I I knew he had some aerial dog
that dog Oh Mike Oh what no controller
what happened
no it was just like I am someone had
hidden I was making an approach rap I
needed a little point absolutely nothing
make contact with the ball yeah yeah
that's what - from my head's at
try no try to hit it once Oh
little chimp the slowest aerial in
rocket League history ha ha
that wasn't even Ariel I don't know
watch me go I got oh oh friend request
uh-oh and so it begins it's a hope you
kins bicycle I definitely did oh oh
somebody finish it
Oh No thank God
oh you dog and it's an der boo
get it out
yeah and your boobs like his wife
Oh No Oh Rousso got the u.s. airman
scars what
Oh
yeah sabe
all bounce
ah here we go
oh Idol oh come on relax that are there
oh crap oh no oh yeah oh wow the big
save big save why'd I do that I'm so
sorry
or I put it back into play
this would go into an OT dammit or maybe
now here comes more dog oh no what did I
do what have I done
no I botched that that's a great oh yeah
yeah yeah MK was hiding waiting in the
wings lurking lurking Ariel
cars ever once - oh no that's okay
oh is it Oh
Oh Oh aah
Oh No yeah oh it's still alive
pop it up Rob come on no hay and
accidentally hit like score it ourselves
I mean ourselves no thanks everyone for
tuning in again on our rocket launch
livestream on the Nintendo switch really
appreciate everyone tuning in and to all
the players that we got in currently to
play with us in a private match yeah
showing off that cross play we played on
handheld we played with a pro controller
we've also split swing screened all
during it Wow Wow
[Music]
Oh
sorry Mike are you
oh what a save
and every retina and near vodka math
Majumdar know we are so screaming we're
gonna go probably for one more match and
that's it
this will be our last match again wanted
to say thank you guys all for tuning
into the Nintendo switch rocket league
launch didn't know it's out on switch
today $20 we're doing some cross play
right now we made a private match
playing with some of the folks in chat
you guys probably already know that cuz
you're eating chat yeah that's Rob I'm
Eric hello having our fine fine Tuesday
thank you everyone yeah all right
uno mas yeah last one this will be the
last one uh how is the performance on
handle I think it's pretty good it's
pretty solid I've been having fun if it
feels a little weird at first just
because of like you know like getting
used to like the width of it I guess a
little bit yeah general like I mean we
played so much on like ps4 yeah and PC
that like it you just having your like
classic and you know confined controller
it's a little different but I'm used to
it now like you just can't play couple
matches it all comes together so pretty
good stuff yeah absolutely
roofs tow ready I'm so ready up but it
holding us back here we go
pointless video says I'm toxic zombie
yeah you are Oh Jake Jacob Clennon
saying thanks guys are playing had a had
a blast playing goodbye see ya have a
good one yes sir joining in
Switzer link the resolution goes down a
little bit and the screen smaller but
totally serviceable I feel like we could
do that we could play that way if we
want to show the family some rocket
League get the kids playing you know
for the kids well the children Oh ports
yeah uh-huh
we got that hot extra live stream Friday
ooh
as too hot though so tune in yeah that's
going to be a marathon with all of our
other offices oh that's you Australia
and UK no non-stop non-stop can't stop
won't stop dribble it with your shark
fin dribbles with a shark oh damn bird
dog nice little that's a little touch
touch pass there watch them school me
here takes me to school Boop Murtagh
good nice shot nice shot
Oh
whoo that's a close one no no problem
indeed toxic
hello can Ariel actually Ariel
why Wow we got a couple of solid vets in
here I feel like mm one kale three solid
murder dogs been gettin gettin up there
with the aerial game toxic zombie rap oh
and remover sorry again
Maurice hello we meet again
do it Rob
perfect
Oh No okay we're good Oh
oh come on
toxic Oh too much too much
I think someone hit him yeah you know
that was almost a really nice wall game
there spider-man ass Oh
Danu Mike
Oh
damn
[Music]
oh shoot rats Oh shrap nice Wow
we just can't stop running into each
other you and me yeah
it says a lot no way I should just go
and read chat right now I'm just
thinking about how I haven't really run
one else other than you
oh god no that was gonna be not even
close to an aerial oh sure
probably me
[Music]
all right we got to do it blue oh crap
it's not over yet nice all right that's
it
let's do it let's huh Oh ender boo let
me have one pass no like almost knocked
it oh no ok no we're good we're good
oh we got 25 seconds rob oh oh yeah m1k
oh all right we couldn't go out on the
stream without a hot little overtime
potential to play here James German
dharman we're actually playing cosplay
right now with some of the folks in chat
room I believe mm-hmm oh you're still
just a man unless someone really lucked
out by typing GS GS and password GS like
oh damn I looked out
nice good look Rob can we do it oh okay
zombies got it
perfect
oh no I got punted back
right yeah right to them
No
Sam its car alert what
all right your sacrifice will not be in
vain
no good oh no okay whoa look at that
wall game spider-man
oh yeah yeah that's right let's see it
where weren't you was a liar lie it was
like oh you are like a bird you gotta
fly away tgd guys GTM 1kl that was
pretty hot stuff exact in the twitch
thanks for everyone pointless video aka
toxic zombie thanks for hopping on and
helping us out there
team blue there with a clutch win fun
stuff though thanks so much guys thanks
everyone again I'm Eric that's Rob
thanks for tuning in and hanging out
with us in our rocket League Nintendo
switch launch livestream brought to you
by our friends over at rocket league
it's been a fun day
yeah great way to start my day
absolutely a little rocket League on the
switch little portable action will pour
portable a portable action here mobile
works great yeah you can play split
screen with your cons if you want to pro
controller obviously or if you just saw
I want to play on your couch or on your
you know bed or something here you go
you can play handheld but thanks
everyone
$20 out today stay tuned for the rest of
the week we'll have more live streams
course extra life but yeah thanks
everyone for tuning in and I hope you
guys have a happy Tuesday thanks Rob
yeah thank you
music mmm dick where you go Kirkuk